even when you hear populist rhetoric from
the right, it often is followed up by the
worst policy ideas or blame games. Sometimes
FOX News propagandist Tucker Carlson sounds
like a populist, not that different from Bernie
Sanders in rhetoric, except in the next breath,
Tucker will warn you Black Lives
Matter might steal your house.
And so you need our version of right wing
populism to protect you from that. Or
it'll be immigrants will steal. He'll sound like
Bernie and then say immigrants are making us a
dirty, poor country, which he has said before.
And very often, let's be frank, guys, it is a
very it is Hanukka. Very often the tropes go to
the Jews. The anti-Semitic tropes will bubble up
in the most unexpected or maybe expected
places if you know what's going on. And
that's where Tucker went with a segment a couple
of nights ago. He starts with the perfect lead up
to blaming Jews, which is to talk about people
conspiring to secretly control you. If I've ever
heard a good premise for an anti-Semitic
trope, it's that. Take a listen to this.
Welcome to Tucker Carlson. Tonight, we pay close
attention to a number of big elections recently,
but it turns out that many of the most important
elections are the ones you hear nothing about.
The news media barely covers them. Most voters
don't know they're happening. As a result of this,
a small group of committed extremists gets to
control the outcome of those elections, often
with disastrous results. It happens all the time.
And who is one of those people secretly conspiring
to control you and others? Well, of course,
it's old, rich Jewish guy George Soros. This
is this is beyond parody now. But that's
where Tucker is going with this. Check it out.
That's not democracy as we were taught it.
It increasingly is how things work here.
George Soros understands that Soros has an eye
for vulnerabilities. He became extraordinarily
rich by finding ways to exploit the weaknesses
in systems that he did not himself built.
In the early 1990s, Soros became a billionaire by
shorting the British pound, crushing the Bank of
England in the process. He went on to repeat
those tactics and other financial crises in
countries around the world. And then George Soros
turns his attention to the United States, where he
decided he would fundamentally change our society.
It's actually amazing that for all of the dressed
up populist rhetoric and man of the people stuff
and smart conservative Tucker Carlson, who doesn't
play the games Republicans play, he's back to
blaming George Soros for our problems disguised
with the same anti-Semitic tropes that we've been
seeing for, what, 150, 200 years at this point.
And he continues with this. Check it out.
If you're wondering why so many people are being
robbed, raped and killed in American
cities right now, George Soros is part
of the reason for that. Soros has. Funded the
campaigns of left wing extremists in district
attorney races all over the country, in cities
like Philadelphia, St. Louis, Chicago, Boston,
traditionally a prosecutor's job is to enforce
the law. But Soros wanted rigid ideologues who
refused to do that and instead let murderers and
rapists go free while allowing our society itself
to degrade and collapse.
People are being robbed,
raped and killed because of George Soros. How
did you not know that? Now you know how I've
been saying that in all likelihood, the return of
a normal person to the White House in Joe Biden
means everybody goes back to the normal playbook.
Republicans go back to pretending to care about
the deficit. And these faux populists on the right
go back to blaming the Jews or brown immigrants
for everything. It's the same old playbook. This
is an anti-Semitic trope that goes back centuries.
The rich Jew using subterfuge to control others
and manipulate society almost like a puppet master
behind the curtain, controlling the marionettes
for personal gain. It's just anti-Semitism,
guys. It's well disguised, sometimes
anti-Semitism, but that's all it is. When
the right talks about George Soros, it's code for
the Jews. George Soros is just a rich 90 year old
who survived the Nazi occupation of Hungary before
moving to the United Kingdom after World War Two.
But he's become code for he's become emblematic of
the Jews and most of them know they can't say the
Jews. So they say George Soros. It's a meme and
it's a dog whistle and a very obvious one at that
to many of us. But it still gets by a lot of
the Fox News audience. Now, I know that some
of you will say, David, there is no evidence
that Tucker is personally anti-Semitic.
If if that's where your head is at this point,
then I probably can't rescue you. But as we've
seen with Donald Trump as the perfect example,
it's less about the personal beliefs about
Jewish people or Hispanic people
or black people or whoever,
but it's about playing into the tropes
and fomenting these ideas repetitively,
that that's actually what this is about, arguing
about what's deep inside Tucker or Trump's minds,
that that's that's significantly less important.
But right on cue, everybody going back to the
standard playbook and the roles we would expect
them to have during a more normal administration.